Tom Hanks plays mr. Rogers in the highly
anticipated new movie a beautiful day in
the neighborhood
the Academy award-winning actor says he
initially turned down the part but
director Mary Ellen Heller changed his
mind she's known for the movies The
Diary of a teenage girl and the
oscar-nominated can you ever forgive me
Gayle spoke to Hanks about the new movie
and how Heller convinced him to take the
role here we are this is our first day
on our neighborhood set that's Tom Hanks
right over there I love how you and the
director meet and how this how this
collaboration came about I met Mari at
the week that an article in The New York
Times came out about women filmmakers
and I had read it and literally 24 hours
before I went to his birthday party for
my grandkids and I said oh I said I'll
end up we were chit-chatting blah blah
blah says I'm a director so I just read
this interesting article the New York
Times about female directors have you
seen it
and she said I'm in it I said please
let me remove my shoe from my mouth
so chatted with her there and I heard
about her film Diary of a teenage girl
and I so immediately took a look at it
and said this lady's going places he
said I want to work with her when she
attached herself to this beautiful day
in the neighborhood and after a one read
and a quick phone call with her I said
this is only just a matter of when we
can do it she said she did not want you
to be an imitation of Fred Rogers well
okay so let's start with the most
obvious aspect the look I'm all we gonna
do teeth I don't have the same nose Oh
what are we gonna say you'll have a wig
and we'll do something with your
eyebrows so the rest is about you
embodying the pulse the heartbeat the
sensibility the motivations of why Fred
Rogers
commanded a room in the way that he did
it's a beautiful day in this coming down
remember that feeling it's always
interesting when you play someone a real
person and in there to what degree do
you try to you know actually look like
them or just and as he said embody them
which is really what's the successful
way really interesting you radiate his
kind of being yeah you don't look like
I'm but you are him the vibe the vibe